Later, Steven and I headed into the mountains
to Bongeunsa, a Buddhist meditation temple
founded more than a thousand years ago.
We were fortunate enough to talk
to one of the eight Buddhist monks
who live at the compound,
and the results were enlightening.
(man speaks in Korean)
His name is Haneul.
You must be very at peace.
He must be very at peace in his spirit
and his mind.
(man speaks in Korean)
What is he saying?
He's saying,
"You need to look inside yourself
"to fix your problems."
(laughter)
Which, I mean...
I don't want to look in there, I already know.
It's such a peaceful place,
but the wind chimes are making me crazy.
It's like, peace and then grrr!
(laughter)
Makes me crazy!
(man speaks Korean)
This guy could (mumbles) talking for (mumbles) straight.
I think when you live here and you're around all these
very peaceful monks,
you must have this urge to speak.
It's these wind chimes.
They make me crazy in my head.
Crazy! The wind chimes!
(laughter)
(speaks Korean)
My mind, it's just, like, crazy!
(man speaks Korean)
He knows that you're on T.V.
You know that I'm on T.V.?
You have television?
(laughter)
I really thought we were the first people
to come up here in a thousand years.
(Man speaks Korean)
You have an iPhone?
(man speaks Korean)
What'd he say?
He says he has both.
What does he have?
He has Samsung and an iPhone.
You have Samsung and an iPhone?
I don't even have that!
(traditional Korean music)
(man speaks Korean)
Because the chimes aren't enough, you know.
What'd I do wrong?
Oh, I see.
You're laughing at me.
(laughter)
Let me try one more time.
I think I've got it.
I got it, I got it.
(laughter)
Very different, little difference.
(man speaks Korean)
What did I do wrong?
(man and Steven speaking Korean)
You two are having a big old laugh.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Oh.
(laughter)
What are you going to do with this guy?
I don't know.
(laughter)
Good luck.
It took us years to master this.
(laughter)
(traditional Korean music)
Yeah, yeah, yeah, OK.
I know how to shovel!
I'm from Boston!
We have snow!
(Man speaking Korean)
(cell phone ringing)
(laughter)
(laughter and applause)